Your task was to complete the implementation of the addChoice method, and the
previous step you had added the choice string to the list of choices. Now we
want to take this parameter into account. And if were handed the correct
choice, we want to update the answer. Now the answer is the string, such as
three if we're currently at the third choice. So, over here, we can find out
what the current choice is by measuring the size of the choice array. When
we're at the third choice, there are three choices in the array. The number
that we need is three, but we need it as a string not as a number. That's the
step here. Now, this is the string that we need to set as the answer of our
question. I've talked about that, you cannot simply access the instance
variable of the super class, but mercifully, we have a method from the super
class that does just that, namely setAnswer. So, all we have to do is call
setAnswer. SetAnswer by the way is an inherited method that we simply get to
call. Alright. Now you've implemented your first subclass method completely.
And next, we'll turn to implementing the display method.